you may kiss the bride well it's kind of
what we expected a fight broke out
during Jake Paul and tan emojos wedding
the YouTube stars tied the knot in a
totally low-key totally casual no big
deal ceremony on Sunday in Las Vegas
just kidding it was a freaking rager
that was one of the craziest moments I
think about when do we need our money
leading up to the big night Tana took to
her Instagram story to share a ton of
pics of her and Jake getting ready for
the big event flying out to Sin City
with their friends and generally having
a buckwild time as they prepped to tie
the knot but my favorite a pic of a four
loko adult beverage that she captioned
wedding day necessities you guys I
cannot I also can't with the fact that
the wedding could be watched by fans who
are willing to pay as it streamed online
but the wildest part of all Tana took to
Twitter to explain how a fight broke out
during the ceremony quote someone just
threw a glass of champagne at Jake and I
at the King altar holy ah sorry I really
can't thankfully as we showed you
earlier the moment was caught on camera
for our viewing pleasure you may kiss
the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
of course an eyewitness tell ZT that the
fight appeared to be staged which is
almost as on-brand as a four loko
wedding pregame it was beautiful
yeah its own twisted Paul family wedding
way Tana rocked not one but two looks
for the big event
first opting for a more traditional lace
gown with a long floor-length lace veil
what's up guys I am actually changing
out of my first wedding dress right now
into another one but also my assets top
just wanted to share then Tana switched
it up for her actual ceremony changing
into this white corset style top and a
ruffled pink and white skirt
et was exclusively with the happy couple
immediately after they said I do and
they dished on what's next I'm
surprising her with a lot of honey
I'm so she's getting out of flight
tomorrow okey so you have no idea I know
I know where we're going which I think
this little secret but I know that if
anybody has tricks up their sleeve it is
Jacob Joseph Paul and if you're like me
and you can't pronounce
tannaz last name to save your freakin
life
you're in luck an eight-letter IG name
versus like a 14 first of all Thank You
Nick inadvertently gave me [ __ ] just by
having a short left which is like I'm so
excited about me something tells me that
these two are going to have us talking
for a long time and of course will be
here to bring you all the latest Hannah
Jake news so make sure to keep it locked
right here on ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]